so
pro-abortion house oversight committee
witnesses refused to denounce
infanticide in what may be one of the
weirdest hearings i've ever seen
they were just outright asked like how
do you feel about it and they're like
i'm not answering that i refuse i refuse
the premise women are allowed to get
abortions and it's like okay hold on a
minute like it's not hard just to say no
to this
and apparently there were three
witnesses that rejected this
and so
what's freaking me out here is now we
got uh matt walsh good friend matt walsh
he's uh posted the coming civil war is
going to be weird and that he can't live
with these people he doesn't care he
hates them they hate him
we can't live this way
and um this rhetoric isn't just coming
from say matt walsh it's just he's
trending on twitter right now because of
it we have an article from i believe
it's salon saying that donald trump must
be charged with treason
we have uh i published an op-ed in
newsweek today addressing the smears and
the lies from the january 6 committee
about me
and all of this just says to me
well matt walsh is right i don't
understand how and you've heard me say
it a million times
how we can move forward as a country
when you have people who outright will
not just plainly say like oh yeah
infanticide is bad come on i think one
witness did and three were like i'm not
answering that question why not
that's how divergent our world views are
we have that other clip from with josh
hawley where the professor outright
refuses to say whether it's a women's
rights issue on abortion and then talks
about men getting pregnant and there is
just a divergent world view that neither
will accept now you've got 80 or so
democrats calling for joe biden declare
a health emergency effectively to bypass
state rulings on this this country is on
the verge of something to truly crazy
and i'm not the only person who noticed
that abortion is a strong moral issue
not unlike slavery that could be a
catalyst for something substantially
worse than the crisis we're seeing now
maybe civil war i don't know but when
people just across the political space
are outright saying yes to this on both
sides
all right well i don't have to tell you
then something crazy is going to be
happening so we'll talk about that plus
you add on all of those those challenges
with a food shortage
with hyperinflation
you've got a recipe for very serious
disaster
so we're gonna talk all about that
before we get started head over my
friends to
eatrightandfeelwell.com to pick up your
biotrust keto elevate it's kind of funny
to jump from all of that serious sombra
stuff into a promo spot but we're big
fans of biotrust and i'll just point out
that as i wrote this newsweek op-ed
uh for uh
i i was looking at old clips and
segments where we denounced violence and
i couldn't help but notice how fat i was
and so uh i've been doing keto and a
modified low carb diet i've been using
biotrust eatrightandfeelwell.com i've
lost like 30 pounds uh no joke head over
to eatrightandfeelwell.com and you will
get up to 51 off you will get a 60 day
money back guarantee keto elevate
provides your body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct you get 5 grams of the
highly sought after mctc8 keto elevate
is my favorite mct powder on the market
today uh and this is actually true i
know i always mention that they have
like these notes written down but people
actually brought mct over and i didn't i
didn't like it i really do like the
biotrust stuff
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
you'll get free vip live health health
and fitness coaching from biotrust's
team of expert nutrition and health
coaches for life with every order and
the free e-report the top 14 ketogenic
foods with every order take a look at
the tim cast video from september i
think 17th 2020 where i said that
rioting and violence hurt black lives
matter cause and wow am i fat so i've
been doing keto stuff and it i lost a
lot of weight so i recommend it i mean
as much as you should check in with your
health healthcare professionals check
out biotrust
eatrightandfeelwell.com thanks about
trust for sponsoring the show don't
forget to head over to timcast.com and
become a member to support our work we
got a ton of journalists that are
working every day to fact check all of
the lies in the mainstream press and
bring you news to the best of our
ability that will be true and correct
and you'll get access to our exclusive
after hours show at 11 p.m those go up
uh monday through thursday at 11 p.m so
we'd love to see you there and with your
support we'll keep doing more awesome
work so don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and without
further ado joining us today to talk
about all of this is kurt schlichter hey
tim thanks for having me who are you
who are you uh i'm a noted lover
i know who is this weird guy
uh i am a
noted los angeles trial lawyer i am a
senior columnist at townhall.com i'm
retired united states army infantry
colonel i want to emphasize i was not a
judge advocate
and i am the author of a new book which
is conveniently placed behind me and
discusses many of the topics that you've
mentioned tonight including national
divorce the possibility of civil
conflict uh and what we do about it so
we got to we got we got stuff yeah we
also got libby she's back hey i'm back
super exciting libby evans editor post
millennial
oh hello uh also i'm ian crossland good
to see you everyone good to see you kurt
hey looking forward to be back hear more
about your book because i i've been
thinking this is like every day we talk
about this almost i mean if it wasn't
for the economy i don't think that that
the moral stuff would be such a big
issue but because of this inflation i'm
i'm concerned
smirks over uh
weimar germany i'm getting this 1928
vibe it's uh well let's see we've got
hyper inflation uh political chaos
bizarre perversions normalized yeah i
think you got a good i i
i i think we got to be on the lookout i
think i don't think that's crazy talk
should we do an emergency food promo
while we're at it no no probably not i
think we're good on that count i'm
excited to be back we love to have kurt
on we're going to keep it kind of
low-key this evening love to have libby
back as always i'm excited to talk about
that this this evening right on let's
jump into this first story we have this
tweet from the washington free beacon
a pro-abortion house oversight witness
refuses to say if she agrees with
infanticide
rep norman quote do you support
infanticide killing a child after he is
born witness i do not agree with the
basis of that question but i do believe
that abortion is healthcare i'll play
you the clip but i want to show you this
you scroll down
a second witness refuses to say if she
agrees with infanticide we don't have
infanticide happening what i think is
based on your question you have very low
opinion of pregnant people pregnant
people a third pro-abortion witness
refuses to say if she agrees with
infanticide could you answer that yes or
no how you just characterized the
representative's statement is extremely
let me tell you something we had this uh
progressive on
and he kept saying that late term
abortion doesn't happen late term
abortion doesn't happen and i said okay
i don't care i'm asking you why
democrats tried to legalize that
recently joe manchin is the reason that
didn't go through and he says but it
doesn't happen okay bro maybe it doesn't
happen because it's illegal
maybe maybe it's not allowed to happen
is that is that
is that the point
and if democrats legalize it will happen
let me play this clip for you because i
want to talk about how insane things are
getting as
i assume you agree with infanticide the
killing of a child a perfectly healthy
child at birth
i don't accept the basis of that
question but i do believe abortion is
health care
i'm talking about do you agree i i know
i get that but do you agree i mean are
you in do you support infanticide
killing the child after he's born
i do not agree with the basis of that
question but i do believe that abortion
is healthcare
why is it so difficult just be like yeah
we shouldn't kill babies that are born
okay next question are these people
considered
witnesses right now uh they they are
witnesses i'm not sure they're sworn are
they allowed to be treated hostilely of
course why don't they say i'm going to
treat this person hostile like if the
refugees cross examine them he's trying
to uh they look they've obviously been
highly prepared look when i get a
witness on a stand they're highly
prepared i usually you know i always
have a jury there right so jury's seeing
things there's no jury here this is all
political propaganda and what they want
to do is avoid making any concession
to normal people about the normal idea
that you don't kill babies okay not a
radical notion but they can't say that
they don't want a clip of one of them
out there going you know i think it'd be
wrong if you killed a baby the other
part of it too is they would have to if
they wanted to say that infanticide was
wrong right the next question would be
at what point in birth at what age bingo
does the you know infant have to be
during the gestation process for it to
be infanticide so that's part of the
issue we've had these conversations with
people on this show
with uh and and and they just refuse to
answer and there's no answer and i i've
asked we to progressive and i said okay
there's two women
they got pregnant the exact same time
the babies have gestated for the exact
same amount of time eight and a half
months
one woman gets a c-section
the baby is pulled from her womb the
other one does not
can you abort the baby in the womb
they say yes they're like well yeah it's
a woman's choice it's a woman's choice
what about the baby who's born no that
would be wrong and i'm like okay wait
what why well that's a big concern
that's that's exactly what they didn't
want to answer
right in the house today they don't want
to have to say what abortion actually is
which is killing a baby they don't want
to say they just don't want to say it i
have a lot more respect for people who
say you know i'm in favor of abortion
and abortion is murder because at least
that's totally honest
well
i don't know if i have respect for them
i just
i mean
you're a terrible terrible human being
but you're at least not lying to me
about that person and you're not lying
to yourself like these people are lying
to themselves no
i think that's wrong because they don't
believe anything she knows what
infanticide is she knows what a woman is
but do you know why they refuse to
answer
because they will be attacked by the
left oh yeah because the goalposts move
so rapidly on the left that their their
allegiance is to the cult and not to any
morals
so they're they're probably sitting
there thinking like if i say i oppose
this and then in a week we are in favor
of it i'm going to get canceled
so i better not say anything other than
whatever the approved line is well and
there is no cohesive value system so
there's nothing to base these judgments
on it's what needs to be said look
the left could just as easily been
radically pro-life
if that was to their advantage they
could be saying we are not going to
allow you to murder young babies
future democrat welfare recipients we
are not allowing that
that's horrible that's that's terrible
your human life i you could but they
don't have kids
well there are reasons why they chose to
go that way but don't don't
i mean the the idea that it's some sort
of moral uh choice of theirs they would
have gone the airway if it was useful to
their agenda i i and has been in some
countries maybe maybe but i think it's
useful to their agenda not in the way
you're saying
it's useful to their agenda because they
don't like people because they want to
reduce the amount of people well that's
true this is the funny thing there's a
meme you are the carbon they are trying
to reduce
but hold on bill gates literally wrote
that i think it was in reuters in 2018
saying
poverty is expanding because poor people
are having kids and we need to give them
birth control to stop this and i'm like
they're quite literally saying less
people because it's causing climate
change so these these democrats don't
want people the problem is
when they are more likely to sterilize
their kids more likely to abort their
kids
and conservatives are not the future is
conservative it's just a simple
mathematical equation are you
you're right about that and i and i
think if you watch this they are
conceding
that normal people will find their
beliefs repellent right now
even every time even 30 years ago when
you had bill clinton and you had people
thinking well safe legal and rare which
was a brilliant formulation
even even
gently pro-life people could go well you
know at least he's throwing on all a
branch at least he says you know they we
all agree that this is a disfavored
thing i had a uh a leftist friend go
kurt no one is for abortion well that's
we now know that that's no longer
changing you show them the lena dunham
quote where she said she wished she had
an abortion well there's that she
doesn't have a child she just wanted to
kill ones and there was also there was a
lindy west right who came out with that
book pro and it was like we are
pro-abortion that's what we need to do
well start going with now but but these
people when they're doing politics
not in their own personal echo chamber
they are trying desperately not to show
normal people what they really think
because you go out to a normal person
and one who may be a little bit kind of
well you know she's gotten in trouble
it's the first few weeks i can deal with
that but you go yeah we're you know you
can abort this kid pretty much until he
gets his driver's license
and they're just going what is wrong
with you
no normal human being says eight eight
and a half eight months four
three weeks and go ahead and abort no
normal person they're like what are you
talking about that's way past the point
of viability okay well it's insane yeah
but they're missing but the law their
logic
forces them to accept it but they can't
say it out loud i think it was vosh and
i think it was on this show
he was asked i think i think was when we
had charlie kirk and vashon when did
when does life begin and vos said some
time after birth yeah i think right
that's interesting theologian that
sounds like a mis a misspeak if he said
that because no i mean you're obviously
alive when you're born no they they
genuinely uh there have been arguments
from more extreme pro-abortion
individuals that memories don't form
until three months after you're born oh
it's now memories
so
you don't need to have memories in order
to be able well i want to clarify that
because these are the same people who
insist we eat bugs so we don't slaughter
cattle and pigs
are pigs and cattle alive well it's not
so why it's not about that it's about
climate change well it's about power
they're not saying yeah yeah they're not
saying to eat crickets because they want
to save the animals i mean some people
are they're saying cows fart too much
like aoc put out that thing where i was
like farting cows so see but they put
crickets but of course the real reason
they want us to eat bugs is because it's
degrading humiliating and we enjoy
eating beef
and that we are peasants and we need to
suffer i disagree i disagree i think
it's actually much much simpler than
that crickets are cheap
crickets are cheap and if you can start
a cricket that's cheap i used to buy
crickets for my euromastics lizards damn
things like they're crosstalk they'll be
cheaper once they're massive
do you know how long it takes to get to
raise beef cattle
it takes a while a couple years i was
talking to the farmer and i said how
like you get all this beef they got
tenderloin and stuff it's amazing i love
it and i said how how how long from the
cow being born until like they're ready
to be chopped up and they're like two
years
a cricket is like a week
and so you get a big vet you mass
produce garbage cheap protein crickets
and and here's what happens you're like
not only is it cheap to make
but it's uh it's easy to like pulverize
produce this food
now you need to convince people to buy
it it's cheap to make and there's an
opportunity to invest so people like
bill gates these other people i don't
know if he's he's doing this but they
invest in cricket production and then
they start dumping money into news
programs being like oh you you got to
eat the crickets everybody's getting
busted companies start doing better and
better and better and then they put out
videos of nicole kidman eating bugs and
everybody yeah what would you call it
doc
that's
it's after tom cruise it's the second
weirdest thing
look no i i i think
i think we're overlooking
the remember uh
marxism this whole leftist woke thing is
really a psychodrama and it's about
their feels
there is a certain joy in compelling
other people to do degrading things and
it is degrading to eat bugs uh steak is
the
uh
food of a citizen of a proud male or
female a proud human being
and bugs bugs are what you give to
servants and serves and they get off on
that you know what i love there was like
a post where someone said 80 of the
world eats bugs no and then it showed
well it showed people eating bugs and
then someone responded with like the
reason they eat bugs is because they're
poor well yeah
it's like to the extent you're not
you're not saying they do it because
they're proud to do it and they're doing
cause they have no choice you know to
the extent that they're slurping up
millipedes like uh the you know the dogs
and lady in the [ __ ] i'm sorry uh i
mean it tastes good yeah it's just no we
had cricket
yeah it's nobody's first choice the
first choice of any human being is a
delicious uh grilled rib eye
rib eye
man i would say pasta oh my god
yeah carbs glutens every time every time
be gone with you i had a fillet uh a
bowl of bullionaires on some pasta
i needed a cigarette and a cuddle
afterwards spectacular kurt you said
that the left could easily have just
been anti-abortion um
useful to them does it do you think that
this iteration of the left meaning i
don't know what how you would define it
exactly is it like a communist radical
attempt at an overthrow of the current
state of governance i think it you know
i think it is i think it is a bunch of
uh
uh perpetual
wellesley sophomores living out their
daddy psychodrama issues and the guys
who are trying to have sex with them and
i think that that is
really the essence i think it is a uh i
think they are
there's a space in everybody for to be
filled with some sort of spirituality
you know you know
maybe you're a christian maybe you're an
orthodox jew maybe you're just kind of
spiritual in general maybe you have some
sort of rational belief
system which doesn't involve a guy but
you fill it with something that's not
crazy but if you don't fill it with
something that's not crazy it gets
filled with something that's crazy
that's why these guys have this
religious mindset complete with heretics
us we're all heretics they'd happily
burn us and and and sacraments like
abortion but this is why apostates are
so bad and heavily targeted people who
are like they really don't like people
who were woke and then walk away yeah
look you you were associated with the
left uh
and they hate you
so uh prager uh prager you had that dave
rubin thing why i left the left and then
i told him i was like you gotta make a
video called how the left left me yeah
and i was like because my position
stayed basically the same it's like that
elon musk meme that was actually a colin
wright meme showing how the left is just
continually gone insane and the the
infanticide abortion thing is the
perfect example a year ago they're like
it's not happening you're crazy now
they're like i'm not i'm not answering
that question i refuse like we are
inching towards them to where they get
to the point where they're going to be
like well
you call it infanticide but if the child
is is malformed or it has it's
convenient you know like you know what's
crazy to me there's a meme i see these
leftist posts and it shows a like a slum
house covered in graffiti and a child
sleeping on a scuzzy mattress and it
said just because he was born doesn't
mean he was saved and i was like are you
advocating for killing that child like
it's a it's are you saying it shouldn't
be alive
is the thing they always say right it's
like oh you only care for children
before they're born but if you would
care for them afterwards we wouldn't
have to abort them and it's like
what are you talking about and there's i
have to kill him you don't care you
don't care well you know it it may be a
little rude to our leftist friends but
you know marxists murdered 100 million
people in the last century that's
inconvenient those are interesting
there's there's
they're just cambodians right i love
this there's a meme
from uh existential comics or extensions
comics that i see posted all the time
and it's like it says something dumb
it's like we're made to believe that
communism is bad because a famine
happened once and i'm like yo
how about every time 100 million dead
right
man these people are absolutely insane
but let's get to the the the escalation
of this by throwing it to our good
friend matt walsh
matt walsh tweeted these hearings on
abortion are instructive the liberal
witnesses have refused to condemn
infanticide refused to define the word
woman and claim that men can get
pregnant we cannot share a country with
these people there can be no unity they
are lunatics and monsters i don't
respect them i have nothing in common
with them i detest everything they
believe and stand for they feel the same
about me we simply cannot go on this way
matt previously had tweeted we are a
nation divided over whether pregnant men
exist the coming civil war will
certainly be the weirdest one in history
so
it may be a bit silly
a lot of people keep denying the reality
of what's happening in this country
but um i i don't think matt's wrong when
he says he detests them i certainly
believe he does but they feel the same
way about him they certainly do
so at a certain point we are inching
towards what many people refer to as at
the very least peaceful divorce
peaceful peaceful development i have a
chapter of that in my book right there
will be back phone rise of america i
have to mention it like every time
because otherwise regnary will keep my
family hostage
uh but so so real quick i want to ask
you about that but um i we talked about
this a while back that abortion could be
the moral catalyst like slavery was
and
some people might not think so
maybe maybe not it could be a
combination of things i i think it's
possible that we're in the bleeding
kansas phase of civil war that was the
seven so not quite we're not shooting
yet but i do talk about we're not aaron
danielson was shot twice in the chest in
portland that's true not in a systemic
way i i
don't i don't agree i think the issue is
when you look back at bleeding kansas
this was this was an era where we didn't
have the kind of communications or
technology true
so
people are more tactful in their
strategies for warfare
which is they're trying to manipulate
people to gain public power and access
to resources and direct violence doesn't
work as effectively or it doesn't it's
not it's not effective at all at all
these days in most circumstances so when
you look at the past several years when
you look at the 529 insurrection when
leftists broke the barricades down in
front of the white house set fire to
saint john's church torched the guard
post and forced the president into a
bunker and then the media defended it
the i i pulled up an article from 529
this was mind-blowing and it said that
the democrats wanted an inquiry on the
police actions that's right after the
left
fire bombed a church and a guard post
and the president was forced in the
bunker the democrats were like we need
to know what the police were doing well
and they did do that investigation right
yeah well and then you get january 6
which is the which is
all of a sudden now it's the apocalypse
i i i feel that look for those i don't
know bleeding kansas was a territorial
it was kansas there was a civil war
effectively within the state over
whether or not it would be a slave state
and it never stopped believing kansas
didn't end the civil war just started no
no the bleeding kansas i talked about in
there was
essentially
dispersed decentralized cavalry units
raiding various civilian outposts and
there were a large number of deaths look
you are right that the pre poetic
predicate
uh condition
does exist that is people in significant
numbers accepting the use of
intimidation and violence to affect
political change and we see that even we
even saw it this week with uh you know
i'm going to go get in uh getting
kavanaugh's face as he's eating a rib
eye because ribeye is of course
fantastic they're in a tenderloin
his face now if you get in someone's
face you're not persuading him you're
trying to force him to go your way you
have left politics you have left
persuasion you've left you know uh uh
the the system you're now using
intimidation so if you get this face
where is the moral
uh guard rail that keeps you from
slapping his face to make him do it and
if that doesn't work
where is the guardrail that keeps you
from shooting him in the face so you are
there was an assassin and there was
there was so you are correct there are a
significant number who are accepting the
premise that you can use violence to
affect change keep in mind 50 years ago
we had a low-grade urban insurgency we
had the weather underground black
panthers symbiones liberation army death
to the fascist insect
greatest greatest tagline for a
revolutionary group ever
um and it was treated as a law
enforcement matter but there were
bombings all over the place read days of
rage bombings all over the place a large
number of killings it was suppressed
through law enforcement but that was a
very low grade type of insurgency when i
talk about civil war and i i discuss i
have two chapters i discuss red on
red against a blue government blew
against a uh a red people
uh or a red government um
you know there is a spectrum of conflict
but you are correct about the predicate
which is people accepting the idea that
violence is an acceptable means to
affect political change and
unfortunately there are a number of
people on the left who do that i i don't
know
how great that number is doesn't matter
how many people it does matter because
if it becomes if it starts getting 40 50
percent then you've got a real problem
how many people fought in the civil war
see that's that's when it becomes 40 50
60 70 80 10 yes but the people supported
them so
in our situation like who would be out
there fighting so the question is like
depending on the center front versus
antifa that's bleeding kansas that is
bleeding kansas and that is one of the
things small
informal militias battling it out what's
the government does the government send
in the cav yeah we have but no but not
in large we did see it
it does exist
but it's in pieces but it's not systemic
we had we had rioting in portland for
120 days yes firebombing federal
buildings yes correct we had since what
since when did it start 2017 oh yeah the
battle for berkeley right right right
the the chas
in multiple varieties even even until
recently you had the autonomous zone in
many minneapolis
look
people were shot and killed they they
lit up a white suv with like hundreds of
rounds of five five six because
teenagers read it and they heard a fake
report on the radio from cops that white
supremacists were going to come and
attack them look there
are the conditions
are
uh i don't think they're interested
in provo utah right i think provost is
called yeah they had the ship blm ran up
a supporter ran up to a car and shot a
driver for no reason yes these these
things they happening they exist
but they're not systemic fighting
of the kind
that we saw in bleeding kansas but they
could become it and they right now
they're in urban environments where you
have a unique
set of conditions you always have a d.a
who won't prosecute you always have a
weak government you always have a a
police force that is uh
unwilling or unable to take action
and interestingly even when uh they were
talking about sending in military forces
and i was part of the military force
that suppressed the la riots so i i have
seen this in operation i've seen it
happen i was part of it
um you have uh governors who simply will
not cooperate with that so
that's where it starts to get crazy it
does start to get crazy
we haven't got there yet
i'm
my contention is we could get there
i'd like to take the off-ramp and not
get there what's the off-ramp yeah what
is that well look the the obvious
off-ramp is to convince enough uh
convince a critical mass of americans to
go back
to uh essentially the rule of law and
the constitution
but can we do that and they disagree
with the premise of the constitution
well
how many do we're going to find out
about this they talk about this all in
school right because thomas jefferson
was a slave
so we have to just yeah
they want to increase the number of
people who have this uh
disgusting marxist critique of the uh
constitution yes and and and if they
succeed yeah we're gonna have a real
problem and then i don't know if they
succeeded what's his name like ellie
mistahl or yeah but who reads it who's
gonna read ellie well he's all over his
heart he's all over msnbc all the time
who watches msnbc a lot of people
weirdos losers and mutations i don't
know but what they should do is go
together these are the people
who you're saying we're going to be
fighting right the people who watch
msnbc msnbc's ratings are like 100k it's
like really abysmal and then it's like
people in their 60s
so uh yesterday ladies yesterday i
pulled up an article explaining the
sentiment for union support for the
civil war and you know what the the view
is at least according to this historical
like reference the view was
the union thought the confederacy had
been taken over by a conspiracy of
elites that were subverting the
constitutional rights of the people and
that they had to free these states from
an elite conspiracy
they
believed that
these elites were denying personhood
rights
and i said oh
that sounds like something a trump
supporter would say about today that
democrats are subverting the
constitution locking down churches that
they're denying personhood to babies i
was like it's not one for one but
there's a parallel the reason why i say
bleeding kansas phase is not to claim
that literally bleeding kansas is
happening one for one like that's
identical it's that we're in the
escalation of conflict pre-civil war
which eventually
it's the violence that occurs before a
formal civil war and the reason why i
say that
for one everything we've already said
but but my point is
we can't expect everything happening now
to be identical to what happened back
then for a variety of reasons i mean
technology is one the other issue is
that we are not arguing over which
states will enter the union and support
a cause we're talking about which states
already do actively support abortion to
the point of birth or even after birth
like like like virginia tried to do with
with northam
those those those states are already
ideologically in those camps so it's
looking more like a spanish civil war
or maybe a candidate no it's ideological
it's not geographic
but it's philanthropists against
leftovers
it's becoming geography although i don't
see us as phalanges it's becoming
geographic
take a look at minneapolis so we talked
about the other day there's a video you
may have seen of the fat old dude in
tighty whities twerking in front of the
little girl and a woman walked up to
little girl and waves and no motions a
little girl in a little girl waves
that happened in public in full view of
parents they they wanted the little girl
to engage with it
but i guarantee you
i if i give that video i took it and i
went to an advertising agency and said i
want this it's a pride event in public
with families and kids it's it's
wholesome nobody's nude they're all
fully clothed and i wanted on a
billboard in times square they would say
get out of this building this is
disgusting
but why is it then that it would be
allowed in public in these cities
where are the people like us that would
say that's bad to actually be on the
ground in those places to tell them to
stop why is it that lipstick tick tock
posted this video a father said i'm
going to read for you this book
and the guy said you can't read that
it's illegal and he said but it's in our
schools
why is it that these things are being
allowed to happen it's because the
culture in these places
has moved to a degree where they accept
these things regardless of law when the
law stops being enforced and that that's
what we're seeing oh yes then eventually
you'll see similar arguments we saw in
the civil war which is why are we party
to a to a a country in which the law is
only enforced against us but never
against those who wrong us you're look
you're absolutely correct you're talking
about the predicate conditions for civil
conflict and one of them is a dual track
justice system which we are seeing in
space i mean look at look at the j6
people that's just you know guys sitting
in there in in jail for a year and a
half
where's their speedy trial for their
misdemeanors it is
and it is unsustainable now
how are we going to solve it well one
way i solve it is
political action we either have a courts
that stand up and do the right thing
or we have elections
where we take power back and you know
the next president pardons all these
guys
or
we go outside the political process and
outside the political process
which is where you've accurately pointed
the left is gone
well that that can be really scary and
there is a continuum of that there is a
continuum of of civil conflict and i
look i
and it worries the hell out of me
because as you know i served in kosovo
served where there was a a civil war we
are in the ruins of it and i would walk
through ruined villages and i i remember
one village it looked like just blown
blown down just bombed down i said wow
this told my uh muslim interpreter man
this is horrible but i don't see any
blast marks on any flame marks and he
said no no no the the enemy of this town
came here with crowbars and
sledgehammers and literally disassembled
this town into wreckage that was the
level of hatred i was i was reading
about the french revolution and i was
reading about robespierre and danton i
think yeah you mentioned and the crazy
thing about it
is that uh correct me i'm wrong because
i think you were reading about this it
was basically a bunch of people
terrified of each other
thinking if i don't kill them they'll
kill me
it's usually what it comes to i think
robespierre eventually turned on his
brother in arms which was danton the two
of them together
sparked the revolution and then dan uh
danton just was like hey robespierre
you're becoming too much of a cult
leader it's not about you it's about the
revolution and rupture i was like i'm a
better speaker than you and you'll be
executed and then nobody would stand up
to defend him there's a quote i read
they said
they cared less about their convictions
and more about presenting their virtue
oh they were fearful like what's going
on now they they they feared that if
they spoke up and said this is wrong
they would be condemned along with them
and he was executed for it danton was
executed and that's when i i i was
reading into this because i saw a quote
from i think it was a plato maybe where
he said something uh what's the quote i
tweeted it that uh the the penalty for
refusing to be engaged is to be ruled by
evil men or something that affects yes
and then i remembered the quote from
danton uh what do you what did he say oh
it is better to be a fisherman than
metal in the government of yeah or a
poor farmer i think he said poor
fisherman fisherman was it yeah and
accentuating the poor to be in poverty
than to be metal in the politics and so
i was like pick your poison right do
nothing and be ruled by evil meddle get
your head chopped off and so i started
reading about danton and robespierre and
it really like i read a cursory article
talking about it and it was really very
much like these disparate factions were
all it was a mexican standoff they were
all staring at each other like which one
is going to be the one that tries to
kill us next so then they were like
sounds like the spanish civil war on the
communist side yeah because when they
weren't fighting franco's guys they were
killing each other i mean in in probably
why frank ended up winning right franco
did franco won pretty darn decisively um
and that is one of the one of the
problems with the left
the you know they when they're engaged
you know you you've got to win or you
die for kind of the conservative side
they don't really want to be engaged
so it's not you know
forrest cooper
he said that uh the people who are good
at violence don't want to be involved in
it and that should tell you something
that is true the guys who have seen it
who've experienced it who are trained in
it are like please stop please stop
one of the problems with the left
is
well i i mean i mean look at the
look at the oval day uh footage of the
cops devastating yeah
for i you know
that's one untrained little mutant 18
years old
not not tactically proficient he's got
he's got a weapon
but there's like 20 of them
and and they won't rush him what are
they going to do
about 400 000 guys who are trained and
who are ideologically committed and who
aren't eighteen even a few thousand you
ever tried building a house of course
even five like what would they do
against five guys
okay what happened in boston right two
mutants
two little mutants that's right shut
down boston
two guys with handguns and the
occasional pressure cooker bomb shut
down boston have you ever tried to build
a house of cards
you know you get plenty yeah sure it's
it's it's it's tough it takes a lot of
time and energy yeah and then someone
can go
like tiny tiny and the whole thing comes
crumbling down my point is it is
extremely difficult to build a complex
machine it is extremely easy to disrupt
one i look at it as a jenga tower you
know the little game you have little
blocks
and the leftists
first of all y'all understand the
leftist our ruling class inherits this
jenga tower they didn't build it they're
cultural trust fund babies it was handed
to them they got their credentials at
harvard and then they took their jobs
running the institutions which they have
no
particular appreciation or or even
understanding of they just got it and
they use them for their own power and
they think they can pull out these
things from the jenga tower because it
never never occurred to them how hard it
is to build that tower and it never
occurred to him that could possibly
collapse but it can and that's been
going on for a long time it's been going
on since the 70s there's this great play
by jules pfeiffer called little murders
and uh i don't know if you know the play
but um
everything's getting destroyed in new
york city and it's this wild story where
the police are trying to figure out who
there's like a shooter every time you go
outside people are getting shot the
murders are just skyrocketing as they
were in new york city and you have the
police being like this is a conspiracy
to make the police look bad because we
can't figure out who's killing everybody
but one of the characters is finally
just like destroy destroy destroy when
are you gonna find time to build and
it's like
all of these all of these people have
taken over the institutions camille
paglia talked about this as well she
said the real marxists went out and
lived on communes and all of the fakers
ended up in the universities that's true
that uh that that's absolutely true do
you think in the uh in the age of uh uh
bug protein they're not gonna be able to
get themselves a top sirloin right right
i mean they're gonna they're gonna be
able to do hunter biden is always gonna
be able to get a top sirloin and a nice
piece of ass always going to be vitally
important that leonardo dicaprio fly to
davos to lecture us on our carbon
footprint
i want to bring up this uh this this
article here from salon oh boy was this
finally enough trump and his terrorist
confederates must be prosecuted trump
treason is trending and uh our treason
is trending and it's about trump and
this is one of the articles
i don't i don't care to read the article
for the most part it just goes through
january 6 stuff it shows people who
testified it says enough is enough we've
heard this we know what trump has been
planning trump called for supporters
blah blah blah
it doesn't matter what the sentiment is
beyond
you right now have prominent media
outlets politicians
demanding that the other side be
imprisoned prosecuted shut down they're
um
they're irredeemable i mean we've heard
deplorable and that was a while ago but
now it's it's irredeemable
insurrectionists people have been missed
crystal fascists christo fascists
whatever exciting yeah they're saying
these people are they're saying the
other side is evil and we know it and
they have to be stopped there's no
negotiating with people who believe this
now you just have to beat them met what
and at in in what elections and then and
then
well you can beat them in the political
process
hopefully that's the way you do it uh
look i mean i i in the book i talk a lot
about ancient rome and there's some some
parallels there you know
instead of fighting you know up the
course of honor to become console or
quest or whatever you know it's a lot
easier just to you know
charge your opponent with treason get
them out of the way right and change
that off using the law enforcement
apparatus to go after people and this is
what the january system is
they
but is it will republicans ever do
anything of course they won't
i i don't know i think that look
when john cornyn uh collaborated on the
stupid gun control thing there were fif
14 are republicans who joined 15
republicans right
what's that
thing
on the recent gun bipartisan right 15
yeah the bipartisan sell sell-out thing
safer communities total garbage and of
course garbage you know there's a a
killing the next day of course um
it would have been 35 10 years ago
the the the republican
party because it had because there has
to be a party on the right and the party
of the right is going to be ascendant uh
because of the the insanity of the left
although i'm not sure there it looks
like insanity to normals to us it looks
like a plan
uh and also their failure to run the
institutions correctly seven dollar gas
just intolerable
they're going they're moving to the
right and the republican party will
become more conservative
uh
and the democrat party is going to face
a choice between going even more
hardcore progressive or doing what they
had to do after eight years of reagan
and four years of bush two which is go
more moderate it's a 50 50 government
it's always 50 50 because there are two
parties
the republic the democrats unless they
want to be out as long as they
want don't want to be out of power
they're going to have to moderate if
they're uh happy to be a uh
a rump resistance
and let the uh you know right wing rule
then they won't have to change i think
the issue is
the younger generation is particularly
more partisan and more zealous on both
sides yeah but that's always true
so why would someone whose world view
met walsh for instance to go back to
what he said
that we don't agree that we i despise
them they they feel the same way about
me
in what it's one thing when it's the 90s
and you can see the political overlap
according to pew and it's like
moderate overlap in their world views
today it's it's completely disparate
today it's parents who are bringing
their kids to drag shows
and parents who think that's child abuse
the kids who grew up in these houses are
never going to go and and
agree with i mean look when you get to
the point where an old man in tighty
whities is twerking to a little girl and
they're cheering for and waving to him
and the rest of the country thinks it's
like a criminal offense
the kids who are raised in these
environments are going to be even
further away from each other well and
they're not even going to know where to
find it they're not going to know where
to find values or morals or something
different than that i was at left yeah
they're not going to know where to find
it well the kids like where are they
going to look but it doesn't matter
right but my point is
they don't have them they don't want
them they won't want them they will grow
up around all of that stuff debauchery
and think this is fine and then people
on the right will have traditional
american values and they'll be like
these people are out of their minds i
think i think the one thing that's
missing is i don't think i think a lot
of kids will grow up and think that it's
not fine
and they're not going to know where to
look to find the thing to fill that
total void that's you know just all
depravity they're not going to know
where to look i think conservatives have
done a really poor job in saying you
know over the past like whatever 50
years saying oh you don't want our
values okay you can do whatever you like
and not taking a stand and not saying
you know yes we do need to
have a moral structure we do need to
have this civil religion where we do
have shared values it's at the point now
where like when i talk to people
we don't even have the same value system
we don't even agree on on how to conduct
ourselves in public well libby's right
because i do think there is the
potential uh for the next generation to
embrace actual real values
uh but
it is uh
you know i i look
here's my example remember 10 years ago
when we were told that latinx americans
were going to be the democrats
way to future dominance that this would
be a subservient uh poor caste that
would forever belong to the democrat
party living on scraps from the
democrats and lo and behold 50 percent
of latinx and i just love that word i
just love latinx or is it latin latinx
honey what do you think
uh i thought it was latinx i i i don't
know well latino latina
i'm joking yeah i just like saying that
i just like to see
i want i want to see a couple of
leftists fight it out with pool cues
over the pronunciation but regardless
the latinx americans did not cooperate
half of them are now republican
according to polls because they didn't
want this stuff and they didn't want to
be poor and they didn't want to be
subservient and they didn't want to be
certs
and i
look i i think they're
yes
we need to reach out to people because
we've done a terrible job right now the
republican party is gliding along going
look at that desiccated old fossil
masquerading as a president oh man
that's great he's terrible we're going
to win
but what are we offering we need to
offer culture we need to we need we do
need to offer culture
i think and god yeah we don't want i
don't want cults telling you what god is
you just got to feel it because it's
there it's vibrating like it is it is
you you are be you're feeding it and
it's it's creating you we don't need to
be ashamed of what we believe in a lot
of times it's like well you know i'm
religious but you don't have to be hey
i'm proud to be religious look
i tried tolerance
in the sense that everything was okay
and now they're trying to groom my kid
in kindergarten
all right figuratively i don't have a
kid in kindergarten but a lot of people
do
and that's when the whole tolerance
things are grooming kids yeah they're
not trying to they are actually doing it
i i well
some kids risk a little girl but look
here the the thing is
we need to stop
with this fake everything is cool
everything is not cool okay it is not
cool to have drag queens in schools ever
i don't care if it validates you i don't
care if it's important to your emotional
well-being
it's weird and it's creepy and you're
not grooming my kids and
conservatives basically embraced
relativism yes and that was a mistake
that was a huge mistake because what
we're offering is the opposite of
relativism we're offering a set of
values that is proven over time which
will help you determine meaning in your
life exactly and a set of policies yes
look
we know how to fix crime rudy giuliani
did in new york city he did a great job
remember new york city in the 80s it was
crime city uh we know how to fix the
economy reagan did it and trump did it a
couple years both of them had it booming
we know how to do this how do you fix
the border we know how to fix a border
how do you fix the military we did it
after vietnam i know i was the
beneficiary of it i write about in the
dang book
we know how to do the policy stuff but
we need to get away from relativism i'm
not ashamed to say my values are better
than the values of a bunch of weirdo
perverts who are trying to go out and
groom on kids my values are much better
than people who want to
kill little babies my values are better
and i'm a fight for them
i'm a big fan of of utilizing science to
prove the existence of god because i
think that people of all persuasions can
agree when you look through a radio
telescope what you're looking at for the
most part unless you're blind
unfortunately but we'll fix your eyes um
and you start to see these these
frequencies moving in almost this
intelligence of nature like it's it's
it's becoming even einstein i think the
more scientific he became the more he
started to believe in god i think by the
end of his life he actually believed in
a god even though he wasn't necessarily
religious of any kind that was true with
a lot of philosophers as well who like
you know like kant you know embarked on
this whole conversation about um
essentially
saying that there wasn't really a higher
power but he himself believed and he
believed at the end of his life as well
i think there's a survey they find like
most scientists believing god or
something like that and then you have
all the people who are like there's no
such thing as god it's a simulation and
you're like oh
then who who made the simulation
well no the the argument i love the
simulation stuff because it's like
the questions that philosophers and
theologians have been asking for
thousands of years are being asked for
the first time by simulists who don't
know they can find the answer to many of
those questions
in existing philosophy and and
theology well of course or at least find
the conversation of course right from
there and of course they think they've
been educated because they have a degree
from an ivy league university and they
come out and they are ignorant of their
culture their history their past
if you're ignorant of those things well
because they learn
you're gonna be vulnerable to any
nonsense what what did prager call it
cut flower politics or something like
that is that cut flower where he's like
you can snip the flower off from the
stem in the pot interesting and it looks
beautiful and eventually it dies that's
cut from its roots i think because these
people have been emotionally
disenfranchised maybe through
psychoactive in the water supply
plastics god knows what but like they
need to see the math to believe in a god
like they're the people that will put an
arm in a frozen chamber to watch it get
frostbite to learn about frostbite and
those people need
science japanese
it
that's pretty crazy there's this crazy
japanese uh science fiction book where
the guy eats himself methodically yeah
he's like a cannibal and he just eats
himself he eats himself one person at a
time but there is
it's very japanese i was going to say
it's a very interesting leap from the
start of the segment on trump being
arrested for treason to a guy eating
himself
it's not it's not as weird as the
tentacles this is a spectacular book
actually like a woman a woman ends up
criminally punished for having done
something and she gets uh she gets
planted in a park like a tree
and her family comes to visit her and
she's a tree and eventually she's just
this
a tree she's a tree okay that's weird
are you talking about like like um jinji
edo stuff or something i don't remember
who wrote it for a while i was really
obsessed with the japanese fiction and i
read like all of kobo abe who i think is
just
stupid brilliant like so amazing but the
to your point about science i was
teaching um catechism at my church for a
while and there'd always be like a
couple kids who were there whose moms
are just making them go and they're like
i'm an atheist miss libby i'm an atheist
and i'd be like okay you could be an
atheist that's god doesn't exist there's
no afterlife and i'd be like okay
so you're an atheist so you're into
science and stuff yeah you know i was
like okay so if if energy
can't be destroyed or created what
happens to your energy after you die
and that would always and i mean it's
very simple it's like nothing right and
they'd always be like oh i wonder and
i'd be like yeah go wonder and i'll see
you next week and we'll talk more about
you know the gospel according to matthew
so
that's so
there's like a result so what is going
to happen to bring it back to what we
were originally talking about we're
looking for solutions to the off the off
ramp i i think it's god i think it's if
people can start to believe and i feel
bigger than their own body but this is
this is you're jumping so far beyond
it's like you may as well just say this
problem will be solved once everything's
good and the problem is solved well no
no
there's a way to call it getting people
who are in a cult to break out of that
cult is the challenge but okay the
problem is when people try and do it by
telling them christian god because
they're very resistant but that's not
that's not what we're talking about
that's not what's happening what's
happening is is is beyond
the the religious now certainly these
people are inferring religion on a lot
of these issues it doesn't have to be
religious but i don't understand what
you're talking about what's talking
about science i'm talking about what is
that
about conscious unification we need to
bring people together okay
so
let's let's slow down
you have a faction that's in a cult you
look at these journalists like the nbc
news team is fantastic you run their
twitter accounts through ground.news
bias fact checker and it's like 100
left-wing they don't consume or interact
with any news that comes from the right
none
so they're in a bubble
that's why they believe cop right now
lies covenant catholic lies that's why
they believe jesse smilet
how do you get people out of a cult well
we know how you have to physically
separate them from the cult and then
help them reacclimate to normal
functioning society or entice them to
physically separate themselves
well that's literally what i just said
you just remove them you said physically
remove them yes you could do that you
could take a kid that's in a call and
give it put them in your car and drive
away bro this is nothing this is you're
making there's multiple ways to get
people the point is is that people need
to be separated from the cult period i
get it let's get the semantics out of
there so people have to be separated
from the cult the problem is they have
cell phones and the cell phones keep
them attached with like an umbilical
cord into the cult interesting that's
what kirk said today digital pacifier
yes whenever they're presented with
information that would shock their
system they start breaking down and they
retreat back to the cult and say give me
the things i need to believe
how do you break someone out of a cult
when they're wired into it
that's the challenge believing in god is
irrelevant they're in a cult you won't
get them to believe in god or find
anything or self-reflect or even take
psychedelics so long as they're entitled
well you can but they're wired into you
can alter the well of the cult like you
can change an entire cult belief system
well that's what we're trying to do
right i mean that's that's sort of what
we're out here trying to do like hey
look at it this way guys look at it this
other way you're looking at it from this
they don't they
remember perspective and you know it can
be a little bit like i got my mom to
stop watching rachel maddow and then i
got her to stop watching cnn
and now she says things like i'm proud
of you and
[Laughter]
it's amazing my friends brand new please
there is one thing you need to do to any
one of your family members that is in
the cult that believes cnn believes
brian stelter don't get mad at them
don't argue things with them just send
them the twitter video from libs of tick
tock of the old men and tidy whities
twerking for the little girl that's it
just send them that
say nothing else
and then be and then just
send them videos like that with with
nothing else don't don't say donald
trump is good don't make points don't
give your opinion just show them a video
because they'll pull it up without
knowing what it is and they'll press
play and go huh remember it's very hard
to convince people but but
people do convince themselves a lot of
people leave cults a lot of people chose
to leave scientology a lot of people uh
chose to leave was it keith raniere the
nexium is that was next they left they
eventually looked at it and occurred to
them this this no there's something
wrong so a significant number
will leave on their own you're we're
talking the hardcore ones who are first
in line to get the uh you know get the
kool-aid
but a significant number will leave
and a lot of conservatives are former
left i don't know a lot of leftists who
are former con actual conservatives so
the bulwark guys don't count the issue
don't message your family members saying
hey you need to watch this video for
this reason don't do any of that
because we we learned this from brandon
strzok he said someone sent him a video
now in his instance it worked but he
said someone sent a video and he was
like i don't want to watch it i'm not
going to watch it
he has a really interesting story and
then he said you know what i'll watch
this to prove them wrong and the video
woke him up
so the issue is when you send someone a
video as an argument they'll many of
people will resist and be like no i'm
not watching your argument but if you
just had a family member a video saying
nothing they might just go what is it
and press play and then they see a fat
old man in tighty whities twerking for a
little girl and people cheering and
clapping for it and they go
what is this
it's like then you can tell them what it
is it's clear and it's like their
spirits like
oh my god what have i been doing
people didn't understand
when we are growing up we are building a
world view in our minds and by the time
we're around 24 to 28 our mind has
solidified on our world view for the
most part
and this is a survival tactic
in evolution that if you have made it
this long what you did works don't
deviate you have learned
when people are then presented with
worldly information that contradicts
their worldview it is a threat to them
which is why they get angry and shut
down or have panic attacks we have heard
it over and over again from people like
brandon
that when they were finally exposed to
undeniable information it was physically
painful they felt physical pain it was
like something was being purged from
them
people will resist that pain like a drug
addict which means you have to be
careful tactful and precise when you're
talking to them when you're sharing
information with them
if you approach someone as an enemy they
will shut down
if you approach them as a friend they
will open up
so don't argue with your family members
insult them listen to what they say what
they're concerned with and then be like
wow i didn't know that check out this
video and then just send them the tour
you don't even you don't have to agree
or disagree too you can understand
something without agreeing or
disagreeing with it well remember you're
not using argument in the traditional
way look when i go to a court when i'm
doing a case i got 12 people and they've
got to sit there and the judge will yell
them if they're not listening so they
have to at least receive it whether i
can convince them or not it's a
different question
that's that's the power of my evidence
power of my presentation
when you're trying you know tim's
absolutely right when you're trying to
convince somebody to get out of the
leftist cult you have to let them want
to do it
and you it remember there's a lot of
pride
because you know if you're if you find
yourself in a position where you're
defending tidy whitey guy twerking in
front of kids
and you understand at some level that's
bad you're ashamed because you've done
that you don't have to rub their face in
it
let them come around although they got
to talk themselves out of it a lot of
times they don't want to right right i
know it feels like it feels good to be
in a situation where everyone agrees
with you
it is
for boomers that tidy whitey video is
like a giant red suppository right
it ought to be quite the pill
it's a painful wake-up call for a lot of
people a lot of people didn't know it
was that bad yeah and and and exactly
we've heard that where people have told
us like oh my family member says that's
not true that can't be happening we had
uh richie mcginnis's mom
old-school feminist yeah and we're
sitting here and i said feminists are
pro-war and she was like no they aren't
and then i said okay
let's clarify that the people who wore
the pink [ __ ] hats are substantially
more likely to be the ones waving the
flags of ukraine advocating for us
intervention in eastern europe into war
and she went what and richie her son
says
yeah yeah actually that's true
and she she's older and so i said listen
i think the issue is you're older you're
kind of tuned out to what's going on in
the world and the younger generation is
on the battlefront that you aren't
watching so you can't believe any of
these things happen
but you need to listen and watch and
look through the window and see what's
out your front door and tidy whitey man
is that cold slap in the face for the
boomer generation look anything that
involves kids is is
really going to be you know the the
nitrous oxide that yeah you add to the
supercharger and the engine just goes
you know way into the red i mean the the
idea that virginia which is a blue state
would put somebody named like glenn
yunken who is a fairly conservative guy
he's not
you know a hundred and eighty pounds of
miracle whip stuffed in a five thousand
dollar suit like mitt romney is
okay i mean he's he's actually here whip
is a great insult yeah that's really
nice he's not even mayo mayo is a proud
condiment a miracle
he's just so basic but uh no he he's
actually conservative and the people of
virginia chose him and the reason they
did it was you know kids coming home
going mom dad why are you all racist
yeah you know open to me this happened
like this happened after the george
floyd stuff right and we were doing the
virtual learning because of stupid coven
and uh i heard an announcement on the on
the classroom computer screen that there
was going to be a two-day lesson on what
was it systemic racism and white
privilege and i'm looking at that i'm
looking at my kid who i believe what was
it fourth grade has it been that long
who was like uh the only white kid in
his class you know we live in a very
immigrant neighborhood in brooklyn um
which i like my neighborhood and uh
he was like i was like okay i'm gonna
record this whole thing i put on the
voice recorder for the the full two days
i i wrote about it but afterwards i
talked to my son about it and he was
like mom we're racist and i was like
we're not racist honey and he's like
well or my grandparents are racist i was
like they're they're totally not my
parents are not raises either well our
great grandparents we went through the
whole thing and i was like your
great-grandmom taught at like integrated
schools in brownsville brooklyn she was
really proud of the work she did you
know your grandma was a public defender
in philadelphia she was like defending
eddie africa and like all these guys you
know like of the series guys the move
guys yeah from after the 78 the shooting
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that was in the
80s yeah but i was like
we're definitely we're not only not
racist our family has a history of not
really being that racist you know well
look we do it yeah working to not be
raised you know i was on with prager the
other day asked me an interesting
question you know in connection with the
book he's like a lot of people will you
know accuse
you know you know kurt you're
you're you your family
served in the civil war on the union
side your your
hometown was burned down by the
confederates uh
you know you're
obviously northern european people will
call you racist but you have this family
history how do you feel about that and i
say i i said well
i'm not
i'm not responsible for my family i
don't get the glory of being part of the
union because that wasn't me
and i don't have blood on my hands
because that also wasn't me
i i i what counts as the contents of my
character
and that's it and that is the answer
most normal americans will give and it's
a very attractive answer well it's an
american answer it is literally the
american american and normal people will
respond to that if we get out there and
say but there's so many people who are
afraid to confront these little weirdos
you know i don't wanna get called a i
don't wanna get called a racist i don't
want to get called a transphobe i don't
care what people who hate me call me
don't share at all should we have the
government pay reparations to the
descendants of people who died in the
civil war to fight for the union so if
like you're you know great great great
grandfather was a union soldier
and he like kissed his wife goodbye and
there's the baby and then he was like i
am going to fight this war to free the
slaves and end this moral
abomination should the us government be
like those people lost their lives and
deserve payments absolutely not uh no
corruption of blood no glory of blood
well that's yeah i agree yeah we have
collective glory in the united states
because we fought a giant war and
slavery i'm proud of my country
as my relatives my relatives aren't me i
don't get to go and like share i mean
that's ridiculous
right
you don't it's like you don't believe in
a loyalty yeah you i don't believe in
the sins of the father you're an
individual you make your own choices
neither does the neither does the you
know the american republic also doesn't
believe in the sins of the father you're
you're not responsible for your
debt
so i wonder if enough parents are going
to be
so covid
allowed parents to hear what their kids
were being taught that's all ending now
and the kids are going back to school
so i'm wondering if now parents are
going to fall back asleep well you do
this is a fluke essentially no i don't i
think that there's actually a lot of
parents who are not and parents have
gotten organized like if you look at
moms for liberty and tiffany justice who
you know founded that group they have a
summit coming up this weekend in tampa
florida which is going to be i think
really exciting very cool yeah it's very
cool and
moms specifically are not going to let
this drop
and if you look at them they're it's
like this very diverse group of educated
moms who really have no interest in
watching their kids be indoctrinated or
watching their daughters you know
end up trans and their grandchildren are
getting
butchered before they can even you know
be born all of this stuff um i think you
have a lot of parents who i think that
we've seen a lot of that if you look at
like the whole desantis movement
parental rights and education bill that
bill was wildly popular across the
country despite the white house's
attempt to brand it as the don't say gay
bill you know i mean parents looked at
it and they were like yeah schools
shouldn't be keeping the mental state of
my kids a secret from me they shouldn't
be calling them random new names that
the kids came up with the democrats lied
about it yeah yeah democrats
the media lied about it they lied about
it very effectively people who are in a
cult and don't want to take their
fingers out of their ears believe it
mm-hmm so that that the issue is that's
the thing we even had a thing we often
had a thing at post millennial too where
you know
they kept calling it don't say gay bill
in all of the press so you know i'd open
up an article to edit it and it would
say the so-called don't say gay bill and
i kept i kept getting in touch with
writers being like no no we're not using
their language we're not going to we're
not going to secede language to them
they have it all right they're making up
stupid definitions none of these words
mean what they tell us that they mean
and that's not what the ability is it
was the don't say straight bill because
it prevented teachers from talking about
heterosexual marriage it was that too it
was and now and now following the
supreme court's ruling
where the guy prayed on the 50-yard line
democrats are pushing don't say pray i
think they just called it the don't
don't they just called it don't don't
yeah don't just obey us just do what we
say don't it's the don't bill i thought
that i thought that was a great ruling
about the the coach the praying coach oh
yeah what's that all about well he
wanted he would pray after again after a
game was over he would go out in the
50-yard line i believe football coach
and he would just like say little prayer
and uh players started joining him and
they would come out and they'd be like
we're gonna pray with coach too and it
turned into a whole thing he didn't tell
them to come out there there wasn't
anything special any special treatment
for the kids that would go out and pray
he would do like a prayer in the locker
room voluntary anyone could join anyone
could not join it wasn't a big issue
and he i think he got fired he did get
fired because he wouldn't give it up and
it's it's very interesting what's
interesting is
you guys know a concept of standing you
have to have suffered a injury an injury
before you can bring a suit uh
what's the injury
that would allow the plaintiffs suing
the uh school district
over you know this guy praying because
that because they fired him because they
said we're gonna get sued what is their
standing
offended the students who refused to
pray were ostracized or excluded or
negatively impacted by refusing to be
party to the prayer they would have to
articulate that uh there's the problem
that it's not true
but yeah i i look that
this is more leftist control and i i'm
glad we have at least one institution
the supreme court that refuses to go
along with it now we have uh dozens of
other major institutions of society are
completely controlled by left including
our military
well that's collapsing oh it's a
disaster it's okay it's chaos sixty
thousand was it sixty thousand guardsmen
uh reservists not allowed to drill like
we they they're they're at forty we're
halfway through the year they're 40 of
uh recruiting goals so their idea was
well let's just cut the number of end
strength right right you know i retired
seven and a half years ago uh as an o6
uh i know lots of other kernels and uh
it is unanimous this is a design and
it's not just we you know back in our
day it was tough when we did basic
training no back in our day we won wars
what's the solution to that yeah
what is going on well you should buy my
book we'll be back the phone rise of
america uh look uh the next president is
a
going to have to not be impressed by
generals and uh you know donald trump
was donald trump like credit likes
credentials he does like shiny things he
likes sharing things oh this guy dr oz
went to harvard okay not a good thing
not a good thing sorry ben shapiro love
you not a good thing trump went to an iv
too right uh he went to work he went to
penn and wharton yeah
but he he was very impressed by generals
uh
here's the thing if you're going to
change it
you need to spend time as the president
remember it's a hierarchical
organization
we always say soldiers do what the
commander checks if the commander checks
wokeness that is if that's his intent
you're going to get wokeness because
it's an organization that responds to
the commander's intent if you want
combat readiness that's a different
thing so you get a president in there
first day fires all joint chiefs brings
in new joint chiefs says guys it's
monday it's 0
this is my intent this is not a decision
briefing this is called an orders
briefing i am telling you what you're
going to do you're going to come back
here friday
friday each of you will brief me about
your organization including you space
force guys
and you're going to brief me
on
how you have
ended diversity equity and inclusion no
more months diversity inclusion and
equity
you died
because that's what soldiers will do if
they're going around learning to hate
their buddy rather than learning to
fight so we're gonna we're gonna end all
that you're gonna end all months there's
no more pride month there's no more you
know southern northern norwegian month
we're not doing any of that uh you're
going to take it out of west point
you're going to take it out of war
college you're going to take it out of
everything every civilian who's in a
slot that includes the word diversity
inclusion or equity is going to be
terminated as redundant everyone who's
military in a slot that includes one of
those words is going to be moved into a
combat unit come back here at 9am on
friday and tell me you have done that so
what you're looking for is a leader with
integrity i'm a leader who understands
how to lead right and you know don't
have one of those in a very long way
well donald trump didn't know how to do
it he did a better job than by than
biden
i think donald trump was a great
president
one of his problems is he's impressed by
the military he needs to
beat the pentagon with uh you know a
whip and a chair
and make it bend to his will you fire
enough general you bring him in that
friday have you done it general well you
know sir
you're out you're gone trump would be
got that right you're fired
and and the little kicker and you are
ordered not to retire until i
investigate you to determine if you
retire as a 010 and not a 09 because you
retire at the last
rank where you performed adequately
um
so you do that a couple of times
essentially
you retire them at a lower rank oh wow
they don't get yeah i mean you don't
take away a star oh i if i were the
president if i were advising the
president say uh i don't know a
president with naval experience like
desantis i would say put a little box on
your desk
and you know if a general doesn't like
what you're doing say general you can
put your stars in there and you can
retire because you can tell me i will
not be part of a military that refuses
to have uh transsexuals serving on
active duty and i respect your integrity
you can put your stuff in there
uh and you put your stars in there and
you'll no longer be in the military and
then your deputy will do what i have
said because i'm president when they
come back friday morning and tell you
we've done it how do you guarantee that
it's actually done because these guys
work on shell games on trump uh
yes and that's why you
the second part is the political unit
within the within the white house that
actually monitors not only the military
at first but others and looks for
cautionary examples for instance hey i
saw this story on the web mr president
about a chaplain at omendorf air force
base who is told he can't mention jesus
because it's not inclusive great
general air force secretary i want you
and everybody in the chain of command
down to that chaplain in my office
monday morning to brief me on how you're
uh meeting my commander's intent for
religious freedom
so come on in here and explain it to me
and you come in and when they don't
explain it to you right you fire
everybody in the chain of command and
everybody gets the message that oh wow
somebody post something on the net and
it's bad
the president is going to have to answer
for that because there are guys looking
for reasons
to screw with people and that's what's
happening now but the other way around
yes exactly so like people are getting
in trouble for posting the gadsden flag
bingo but the funny thing is the gadsden
flag is like a license plate in virginia
yes right so there were uh this was when
they were doing the dc deployment there
were reports that people whose facebook
pages had posts like the guessing flag
were being removed from the mission
and but it's like the flag you see you
go to virginia all the virginia license
plates are gas yeah it's very easy
you know secretary of defense bringing
everybody from that guy's company
commander up to the trump
i don't know if trump would do it the
sandisk i think desantis could do it
because he understands if he does it
about three or four times
the message is going to get out that now
the commander is checking combat
readiness and he's serious he also seems
to stick to his guns desantis which i
just appreciate well to us desantis was
a jag for uh seals so he he he was in a
lot of important meetings he knows how
they work and he knows how generals work
and there are a lot of us guys out there
who know how generals work we'd be happy
to come in and share our expertise look
my dream job is to be a political side
white house i'm the guy who goes the
pentagon sits across the desk from a
general and goes general what would you
say you do here
ooh just like in uh just like an office
space bingo so
so what do you think of a 2024 you think
desantis or trump
uh i think both will run
uh i've talked to people who talked to
trump literally i got a nice note from
trump the other day you think desantis
is going to run i think
has to run everybody seems to really
want him he has to run and i want him to
run because i want a tough primary yeah
i want the best person in 2024 that
makes a lot of sense go after desantis
oh
that's such a good question because
trump look how we roasted elon yeah it
was hilarious it was funny but was it
really that effective
well i mean
like what's effective about roasting
elon they're not really up against each
other it's just trump slapping him you
know figuratively
so
but with trump and desantis desantis is
why is wildly popular especially among
trump's base
and he's he's succeeded on every front
he's doing great it's tough for trump
because you know he has this guy and de
is a smart guy he's not going to attack
trump he's going to go you know i know
the president's running i'm running on
my record i respect the president and
i'll be happy to support him if the uh
voters choose him here's what i've done
in florida now what's trump do that
would actually be effective that would
be super effective that really would be
uh take the high road what's trump do
does trump attack well you know sweaty
ron desantis
and it's like or whatever and he'd be
like yeah i work hard he's like i'm in
florida
just laugh and go well you know
president trump he's he's a funny guy
here's what i've done in florida you
know and i'd like to you know draw your
attention to my successful personnel uh
policies right you know like like i say
for every rick grinnell and robert
o'brien uh trump's got like 10 john
bolton's okay
actually i heard his mustache actually
had to separately get a security
clearance
so trump says he's going to drain the
swamp for whatever reason it didn't
happen maybe it's because he did maybe i
mean he brought him bolton he was like
i'm going to drain the swamp and the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm
bringing the biggest swamp monster
possible
it was a mixed record yes um
and i talk about in the book i have the
last two chapters last chapter uh second
last analyzes all the potential
candidates and talks about trump and
desantis and how i want a primary to
hone the winner i want a strong winner
the last chapter is a president looking
back
as he passes it on to his vice president
rick grinnell and um
how he how he went and did this and and
part of that's the military thing i
talked about but there's a lot of things
to do and you need a president who knows
what time it is and has the strength to
commit the time to fixing these things
rather than just dealing with the you
know squirrel of the day
i kind of think desantis you know
we'll see what happens moving forward
my concern with the tennis is foreign
policy because we haven't seen that and
donald trump i think did really well on
foreign policy oh yeah
his whole bilateral trade thing like his
all of those agreements where it was
like
you know two like agreement between the
us and one other country i thought those
were effective what are those called
those are
yeah
this he settled the middle east yeah i
mean
those are cool that was great you know
i think that was kushner right yeah
kushner was involved and then you had
like the uae accepting flights from
israel which was really cool kosovo and
syria that was cool negotiated by
grinnell
amazing domestic issues desantis does
very very well
uh particularly in florida and coco was
a big deal so i i think the economy
would do well yeah but my fear is
trump has got let's just say character
flaws is a simple way to put it in how
he handles things he lacks discipline
sure but he was he did well by the
economy yes he did well by foreign
policy yes he did well in the culture
war yes and he didn't handle himself as
well as he should when it came to the
media true but people liked that he
smacked the media down
ron desantis seems to have
all that plus the tact
but what if we vote for desantis and all
of a sudden it's like
middle eastern wars again that's why you
have to have this is why you like
cornell right
i love grinnell uh grinnell a personal
friend and uh look i i would sit with
grinnell and when he was going over to
germany and he would ask me
you know when i go to an army base what
do i look for
not like hey i'm gonna have some parties
at the embassy what do i go for what
what am i looking forward to base to see
if it's working right and i would talk
to him for hours about this stuff i'm
very impressed but i mean we need a
primary to to suss that out right
because that's your question i want to
rick you know or says we don't know what
you think about foreign policy tell us
how about endless wars where do you come
on down on those you know i will say
this uh having luke rodkowski on this
show just like ardently defended
desantis over and over again i'm like
that's an endorsement luke hates the
government he's exactly every single
politician and he's like ron desantis
what do you say he saved it saved
america or something like he really did
man he's i mean he he made a bold stand
in an unknown area
against covet the way or maybe not even
against kova just for florida i remember
going to i went to cpac what was it in
like uh
2021
in orlando florida yeah and i was just
like oh my god it is paradise i
it was amazing people were nice you
could go out for drinks and everyone
would smile at you and there were there
were people to bring you food and it was
like they were happy it was so beautiful
i think i wrote an article that was like
florida is a paradise of freedom i'm
pretty sure that's what i called it and
then i had to go back to new york and i
was just like oh god no why
west virginia i i think the issue with
with chris i like west virginia florida
was uh a manual fan yeah westbrook is
great florida was dense now florida is
dense and so you had this dense urban
environment that people who live in
cities like and desantis are like you
get your freedom so all of a sudden
people who like living in cities are
like you got to be in florida west
virginia has freedom
but it's because you're in the middle of
an empty field
which i i love because there's nowhere
really to oppress you yeah your
neighbors like all far away like i don't
care what you're doing and you're like
me neither i kind of love it i don't
care
i think that's brilliant yeah i like
west virginia um
they they for the most part i don't
think there's any lockdowns in west
virginia i'm not sure not not when we
were here how would how would i know
they're gonna come find they had masks
though they're in masks in la again
apparently oh yeah okay but la is stupid
i know and i'm stupid sadly i live there
yeah well i live in new york city but
i'm not going to people walking around
in mass oh but you know what we really
have we have actually something that's
probably stupider than anything you have
which is for a long time after the mask
rules were lifted the mask rules were
not lifted on people under five years
old
sometimes you'll have this you'll have
you know white overeducated liberal
people walking around new york city with
no masks walking a toddler next to them
with a mask on the toddler
were the kids on leashes yes the kids
will be on leashes they have those
little monkey backpack leashes you know
wow yeah so
they're just normalizing bonds just
insane well they are doing that the
washington post wants us to do that
remember they ran that article about how
important it is to expose your kids to
kink at pride gross
fatherly actually i didn't know wow i
didn't see you i didn't see the
washington post uh endorsing eric
greitens that's it was two years ago it
was two years ago that they ran the uh
bring your kids to show them can't get
pride show them kings that's right
luke chatted at us saying desantis has
the advantage over trump okay so if you
look at predicting
uh trump said it's like 35 to santa's 40
to trump but i think
rhonda has an advantage in that he's
actively in government right now he's
campaigning right now which means he's
going to prove himself
right now trump's trump might announce
his presidency early that's the that's
the idea that he's he's announced to
seven
people just before christmas right and
so but
and he has to because desantis is
actively campaigning now for his
governorship
but this means he gets to campaign
actively and be in the press and get a
bunch of attention trump if he sits back
he's losing that space to desantis yeah
do you think newsom is going to try and
run yes oh god i hope so he's
second in line unpredictable behind
biden i believe really yeah what about
camella she's not the worst neighbor she
can get a single delegate she's
remarkable she's together
another proud day for us california
lawyers as as someone who voted for
trump i fear kamala
you know what's funny is uh it's funny
that i basically said that about joe
biden and then joe biden
and so i'm like
you know uh we're sitting here talking
about kamal like ha ha kamala and then
well
it's like the democrats
of the vote in the in the democratic
primary well it's like the democrats
interfering in the republican primaries
they're like let's give the let's get
like 10 million bucks a super trumpy guy
with mega tattooed on his uh [ __ ] stamp
and uh yeah we'll get him and you know
some of these guys are going to get
elected
in a world of seven dollar gas you may
get a guy
uh you know who who changed his name to
john q magga
and he bagel you know this guy seems
like a viable candidate here in colorado
yep so uh i'll we'll talk a little bit
about that we'll do we'll do one quick
segment on this because uh i published
an opinion piece in newsweek today
uh the january 6 committee
misrepresented me
and i'll give you the the quick gist of
the story you guys heard probably the
other day that on national television
across the board there's tim cast they
run this clip where there's people
saying like kick the door in there's
gonna be a red wedding and then in
between it's me going according to fox
news donald trump says there's gonna be
a wild protest it wasn't that you know
dull i said donald trump says there's
going to be a wild protest and i think
he's right considering what we've
already seen i think things will get
wild and i said this could be trump's
last stand he's calling on his
supporters to come to dc
they play that together
and then they try and insinuate that i'm
encouraging people to take action simply
because i'm telling people a thing that
happened so you were just mentioning
how uh what what were you just talking
we're talking about uh
you're talking about the democrats i was
gonna make a point but i forgot what you
were about them funding republicans yes
exactly that was it yes democrats are
paying in one's i think in in colorado's
like 30 million dollars to fund
pro-trump candidates
jamie raskin i'm like why is it that he
put a clip of me because they need to
create an image of a problem
to convince people that they are the
ones who can oppose that problem it is
demagoguery it is a lie the trump
supporters who are getting massive press
it's democrats funding it so they can
then turn to their voters and say look
look at that scary thing only we can
stop it but they're the ones paying for
it it seems a bit cynical
i wouldn't expect it out of democrats
i'd say evil manipulative and cult-like
and and it's not gonna work i mean it
can really
remember how the entire media was uh
pushing for trump for the first time now
they thought they thought great it's
great for tv
and he'll never win this is perfect they
loved it i mean they loved it
let me let me tell you guys something
really interesting about this uh this
op-ed and the january 6 thing i have had
friends
hit me up who had trump derangement
syndrome
being like something's not right here
like i don't understand what just
happened you're a human right i've had
well the thing is
there are people who follow this show
who don't like donald trump
and know at the very least they might
not like me but that i am not what
they're trying to claim me to be like
putting
the the january 6 episode we have was
embedded in the newsweek article and in
it it's like a whole two and a half
hours or whatever of
a conversation as to why violence
doesn't work why we've always condemned
it why this will make things worse why
it's bad and then even in the lead up to
this in september i have a video where
i'm saying that
black lives matter lost all of their
support they gained throughout the year
by engaging in riots don't do this stuff
it doesn't work it hurts your cause and
then jamie raskin
this is really funny by the way his
office is like 30 miles from here
because he wraps the district right next
to us so i'm gonna go to his i'm gonna
go to his office yeah yeah i'm probably
tomorrow i'm gonna go knock on the door
and be like hey guys look i'm here you
guys lied about me
so hey you should definitely do that and
definitely bring a camera question ask
for an apology i like this idea where's
uh
oh he's out getting a haircut you liar i
know you're a liar now well he might not
be at his office in maryland right but
uh it's very close i'll show up and uh
i'll i'll leave a note or something i'll
say hey guys look uh uh i some of my
employees are constituents
of representative raskin and he's
smearing me my company and lying for for
what i believe to be political gain but
maybe i'm wrong about him and he'll
apologize publicly for including me
incorrectly in his in his in his video
well i expect him to take the classy
move and so does my unicorn
that's right
that's right i'm i i think that the
unicorn that's puking uh rainbow glitter
his name's chad great he has a name
i have a feeling i'm going to show you
and they're going to say we don't care
you can't do anything about it we can
say whatever we want and get out i have
a feeling if i show up they're going to
be like you can't be here you need to
leave
that would be interesting too why could
you not be there yeah are you because
you're going to say they're
understanding in your waiting room is it
is it wrong to do that because i was
informed by you that it's okay to come
and petition your representative for
that right it is okay should i should i
hire like a handful of people just hold
signs in front of his office saying he
lied no i think the democratic the
diplomatic approach is right and you can
of course petition the government for a
redress of grievances at least
theoretically it says it for sure well
so the issue with this uh but it also
says you could keep it bear arms
see how that's gone that's going great
yeah no in new york they are like no we
don't we're not gonna follow the supreme
court and they've they're starting you
yeah they're trying to say that the
entire city of new york is like some
sanctuary a sensitive area
when they when the uh
bruin opinion specifically says don't
try that trick you can't do that you
know it's really remarkable how angry
democrats get after the supreme court
says you have to stop violating
systematically violating people's rights
and then they launch into massive
resistance that's right like oh i don't
know brown versus board of education
you know wasn't it funny how they all
these people were like
there was an op-ed that's uh who was it
by i think it might have been politics
girl do you guys know who that is oh
yeah no we we've invited her on the show
before but i guess they just don't want
to do it i'm not surprised and she's
like it's a podcast funded by uh midas
touch oh god but she she what happened
she made a very powerful point against
gay marriage it was kind of crazy she
said that uh something like
the supreme court should not be
legislating and deciding what is law and
what is not law and then i was like that
would rescind a lot well the supreme
court actually
the supreme court sort of said that
recently with the epa ruling right right
and they said you know if congress wants
to do this congress has to do this right
so so what's happened is many people on
the left are trying to come up with some
kind of sophistry as to why the supreme
court is wrong so there's two things one
the supreme court should not arbitrarily
decide what the law is and then it's
like so you agree with the supreme court
that's what they said then the other the
other issue is
they're saying that if the supreme court
is going to rescind its own precedence
then they're illegitimate and it's like
now you're advocating for brownview
board of education oh and you're
ready scott
come on
the supreme court's had a lot of bad
decisions we get rid of yeah yes it's uh
look
we're not here we're not having a
rational debate here you're the the left
is going to take the position that's
most convenient to the left and it's
accumulation of power and money
every single time left power yes
which is why i don't want to argue with
the left i just want to defeat them i
don't and that's why i i never go to the
left with hey
you know if uh don jr had been uh you
know if his his uh uh laptop had been
compromised and his uh you know stripper
antics you know the late doing blasting
rails off the butt of a latavian hooker
videos have been out there you'd be
treating it differently i don't do that
to the left because they don't care it
doesn't matter they're immune to
hypocrisy because
that's that's not what they're about
they're about power normal people though
normal people see that and go huh that's
a problem so we have to keep making the
argument but the argument needs to go to
normal people as far as the left it's
like now you just can't do that here's
what i'll do not letting you i'll take
the twerking old man with the little
girl and i'll do a a a a loop where it
like plays for and then rewinds and
it'll say vote raskin and flash and then
i'll i'll hire someone to hold that up
in front of his office oh my gosh
that's it that's it that's that's
terrific raskin celebrates all
identities yeah just have that down i
want to i won't tell i don't say
anything about him i'll just say vote
for him pride first
hold up get more of this we'll get a
bunch of you know those trucks with the
ad tvs on oh my gosh that would be
hilarious oh that's a really good idea
actually right like the lights with like
you don't know
those trucks that carry billboards yeah
yeah and then just have it playing the
twerking old man and just get like
should we hire like 100 of those and
have you drive around dc
vote jamie raskin yeah no i won't say
anything it'll just show the video
you could definitely do that it'll say
something like minneapolis pride and
just
that's it that's all it is
drive him around we'll hire what if we
did like
you know i think to make it impactful
you need like a hundred of them and just
have them driving throughout the city
you got to be careful not to show it to
kids because that defeats the message
what do you mean there there's literally
a child watching it happen and they're
cheering for it encouraging the point is
how bad that was
saying don't do it again
it is important that people see that
adults see that and understand okay no
no actually that's an important question
would they get mad ian
is there something wrong with it it was
on a public minneapolis street with
people cheering as a little girl watched
i don't see anything where's your pride
maybe i would drive it around after
hours but no no no when the parents
complain about it it's exactly the point
oh
you all have an issue with this in dc
what are you bigots
i'm literally shaking you're just
thinking about that
that why are they denying the existence
of wherever the hell uh tidy whitey boy
is tidy
non-binary whatever the hell he is
there's there's so many videos of this
of this stuff and that video i think is
like the one thing you sent to somebody
to make them be like what
i'm still trying to get over the
twerking legislator from uh rhode island
yeah yeah holy cow oh that was wild
that's pretty bad did you see watch that
on the after show it was pretty amazing
it's like nobody should see that but
you're a gynecologist all right
looking up right now oh no don't do it
people are allowed to work i don't care
i think
when i see that i'm glad she twerked
because i will not support someone who's
doing that you know mac yeah you know
like i don't care that she does it she's
allowed to do it it's america and i'll
vote for somebody else i don't live in
rhode island so i really don't care
although i think
i do think you should mock her and that
comes back to the tolerance thing i'm
not going to say it's okay with me it's
not it's stupid and it's gross and you
shouldn't do it i'm not going to send
the cops to arrest you
uh because first of all i don't want to
get ptsd but uh
you know don't look at me you go oh well
you know i you know you're living your
best life no you're not you're living a
terrible life and you need to stop and
you need some jesus lady this is the
thing with abortion right i mean this is
the thing with abortion too people say
like i had an abortion and it saved my
life and it's like no you had an
abortion that saved your lifestyle and i
don't think it was really
worth saving you know all right we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member for the
members only after hours show it is
uncensored and often very spicy last
night was a whole lot of fun as you'll
see on the front page of the website so
uh yeah check it out and share the show
with your friends all that good stuff
like button like button and uh let's see
what we got
all right what is this ricky longhaul
says thoughts on the usda department of
education irs department of energy
inspector general fish and wildlife
geological survey department of interior
retirement agency stockpiling machine
guns shotguns suppressed pistols body
armor and ammo i didn't know any of that
uh did you guys know any of that no no i
know the irs bought hollow points i did
and the funny thing about hollow points
is that one they're like for killing
uh so they they hit the body they expand
so it causes more damage and i could be
wrong about this but aren't they banned
by like the hog convention or something
hay convention yeah for use in wartime
you're not allowed to have uh
weapons that increase suffering so you
can't have for instance a serrated
bayonet right you can't have like the
double-sided bayonet right
the double-sided knife yeah
yeah right yeah unless there's a
function to it like white phosphorus uh
yeah there's
did you did you know this that they were
stockpiling weapons
i i didn't know that they were buying a
lot of ammo uh i guess they're buying it
now because it's really cheap no that
ain't it
[Laughter]
i saw theories that they were buying it
up to drive up the cost so that people
wouldn't buy it i don't know if that's
true or not i saw that the irs was
buying a ton i saw that they didn't have
a ton of agents who were armed very
interesting little rabbit hole to go
down
yeah i was like why are they buying well
they're like yeah like you're training
whatever else you're doing with it as
okay okay maybe there's nothing here
well if we had some oversight from i
don't know legislators elected by uh
to go you know you're head of the irs i
got a lot of beasts with you i got a
list but why are you buying so much ammo
and maybe he has like a really good
reason oh well we shoot they shoot 250
rounds each well to qualify a year
there's probably
there's probably wild hogs running
around the irs building yeah the irs
building yeah so it's not really just
about the safety of the children who
work in the iris i don't think we think
enough about the children in regards to
armed tax collectors that's right all
right we got nick koenigs who said tim
since i started eating healthy and
running in january i've already lost 50
plus pounds congrats on your weight loss
too yeah the thing is like i didn't i
didn't actually plan on losing weight i
didn't actually care i just was like i
don't want to eat sugar you know we had
the keto stuff and then i was like why
am i eating this garbage all the time
i'm just not going to eat it and then
just i started losing weight i don't
know you talk about a transformation of
the nation man that's that's physical oh
yeah look at those you see those those
memes from the 1960s
and like all the dudes everybody's thin
everyone's thin uh the the other
interesting thing and i look i'm 57
so it's like pulling teeth to lose
weight i've lost like eight pounds in
the last month or so and it's been
agonizing when i was like 22 if i wanted
to lose 10 pounds all i did was go run
for a half hour uh it's a pain but
here's the thing
so many people in the conservative space
do not drink and it's it's not high
flying morality stuff and a lot of them
are
some of them had a problem but others
are like it just doesn't contribute to
my life yeah and that's the majority of
it that drinking is not fashionable
among conservatives the other thing it's
very odd the other thing that's
interesting too is remember michelle
obama had her whole fitness thing her
she had like a whole
anti-obesity thing and now the left is
like obesity is beautiful the sugar
industry the original michelle obama's
original let's move campaign was get
sugar out of your diet and then the
sugar industry came in and was like
there's a documentary that fed up with
katie couric exploits this and uh they
were like let's make it an exercise
campaign forget about the diet and then
they turn it into an exercise and then
but they kept eating
all right
greg says your weight loss is pretty
obvious watching the irl clips can see
the difference between the clip and your
outro clip we're gonna record a new
outro clip
yeah that's great we should do that
after the show i didn't even realize
that i was like oh yeah we have like an
old outro like thanks for watching and
i'm probably just like
i guess the idea of having a theme song
from sir mix-a-lot is now out yeah
tim got back all right
jttv says please continue advocating for
the health of bodies and pushing
critical thinking for the individual
instead of the monolith of absolute
degenerate destructive nonsense that has
plagued this nation for decades god
bless i tell you this i think it might
have been cernovich who said this that
if you really want to win and get back
at the left or whatever exercise eat
healthy focus on yourself make money
have a family yeah people even in a call
people will see beauty and health and
they're drawn to it well i find it so
annoying because like i always feel
better if i if i work out and i'm always
like damn i feel terrible i better work
out that's so annoying i hate that you
know you know yeah
it's funny i really just want to sit on
the couch and watch star trek and then
i'm like
it's fine you mentioned cernovich i
happened to see him at a wedding a
couple weeks ago oh cool and he looked
great and was happy
yeah i mean he was just
a happy guy
we and i i i mean and
you know if you followed serge
sergeiovich's career he was not always a
happy guy
he's like but he's happy now yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
psychedelics he's i mean he's
transformed his life yeah he's i mean
he's gone on an interesting uh uh arc
yeah i mean he's he's actually become a
different person i think he's a much
happier person and he shares his advice
with people and maybe agree with him
maybe you don't but he has all right we
got emily williams says i feel like ian
is that hippie friend you pick up at the
local farmers market that everyone
thinks is high all the time but just
knows way more about weird stuff oh that
seems about right that's actually true
that's what i was going for i'm pretty
sure that's it i think that's wow
mission accomplished yeah
people think anti but he's not
yeah that's cool
when you were a kid did you ever have
other kids go how come you know things
uh but they would just they would lash
out well i was the kid that would raise
my hand for every answer the teacher
would ask because they already gave me
the answer i just got to tell them and
the other kids would would take it out
on me later i didn't know why like why
don't they like me is because i would
make them i guess they felt like idiots
because i was like come on guys move it
along move the story along i couldn't
figure out why all the kids hated me too
like i i was merciless i was telling you
this yesterday i was mercilessly bullied
i know why i was a giant you know now
and then i would raise my hand but
mostly i was just like not ever paying i
was always like just looking at
something else i was always my attention
was somewhere it wasn't supposed to be
all right it's vulnerability people will
sometimes attack vulnerability it's like
a wild tiger with fresh meat like
leftists all right i want to read this
one lars job says my 98 year old grandpa
was found of multiple tumors and he has
almost stopped eating and we believe
he's near the end he lived a good life
and is a world war ii vet the last
surviving member of the alamo scouts if
you know a veteran thank them for their
service
wow shout out to your grandfather i wish
i knew his name i want to shout his name
out that's what a hero freaking cool
you know yeah you got to these these
young americans that i got to serve with
you know they are truly walking in the
boot steps of heroes
uh but they are great themselves i'm so
impressed by our young soldiers
that i worked with and and you know the
occasional weirdo
i really got a shout out haunted autumn
who said are we going to ignore the fact
that tim is wearing the same shirt as
last episode more power to you but dude
we noticed i really love that because
the last episode i was wearing a van's
pocket raglan tv
with print on it what the heck and the
day before i wore this shirt whereas
typically i wear literally the same
thing every single day
so it's like the one time i don't wear
something they think i do come on man
all right
you're being raskins again yeah nikki
hilly says long time supporter just
found cast castle and i'm obsessed can't
stop watching it reminds me of rob
direct's fantasy factory keep up the
amazing work yes
the cast castle is basically going to be
like a hybrid between a vlog and a
sitcom where we're basically making fun
of culture war concepts and issues and
you know poking fun at all the stuff so
i think i i think it's pretty fun and
we're excited to expand it but uh it's a
learning process we start making
episodes we see what works we see what's
funny and then we just make it better
and better and better until it gets
really good and shout out to jamie the
animal killstein
the animal yeah
yeah he's running the vlog right now
he's running cass castle
all right peter
nguyen says right now there's an echo
chamber on twitch the younger generation
is getting so much leftist propaganda
and a political streamers are being
influenced by people like hassan you
need to build culture there you can't
they will ban you for the slightest
thing destiny said kyle rittenhouse was
a was the clearest cut case of
self-defense he had ever seen and they
actually he they call it a band but like
a suspension so simply for asserting a
fact not even a political opinion like
oh yeah i watched the video that was
self-defense they're like you're out
that's twitch for you so not not
interested although maybe for fun we'll
we'll simulcast on twitch for a week to
see how long it takes you can't
simulcast on twitch they well you can't
be a partner on twitch and simulcast
they'll end your partnership it's in
their terms it's very strange there's
software that will let you do it but
twitch doesn't want it i guess weird
yeah it's disappointing i'd be i'd be on
twitch if otherwise
tyler mcfarlane says t-bones are the
superior steak you get a tenderloin and
new york strip in one package fjb um i
agree with with with all of it actually
especially the fj jb part yeah i had a
t-bone and you got the tenderloin on one
side and then you got the strip on the
other and uh but i just you know it is
it is true it's like choose one
commitment yo
just tenderloin filet mignon just um
my wife is a filet mignon person she
likes it who doesn't who's not a filet
mignon person
i'd be a filet mignon person
showing up in my plate every day
sometimes i'm in a ribeye place
sometimes i'm in new york place true and
i will say
it's a different experience yeah like
brisket
you can't even compare brisket to flame
and young they're different things yeah
it's a different thing oh i love
breakfast the best brisket i had was in
austin just recently with uh hannah
nightingale who's uh my u.s news editor
we had the best night and she kept
making fun of me because every bite i
took i was like oh my gosh
are you okay no no i'm not okay nature's
perfect food we can just be so sublime
there was this sauce they like put the
sauce on it
when uh we can talk all day about
abortion and politics we can talk about
the democrats and law enforcement and
trump and january 6. no no no no when
people can't get their brisket they're
going to like kick doors in they're
going to be screaming and banging their
heads on walls it's gonna be chaos that
that is true
you know here's how weird this whole
situation has got i i did a speaking gig
to a bunch of republicans at a uh
country club
and they said it's sold out this is
great i walk in half the room does not
have tables up and i'm like could you
put more tables up and sell them they
said we'd love to and the country club
would love to they could not
guarantee to get enough chicken breasts
to feed the people the last time
americans couldn't go to the store and
get chicken breasts was i guess four
1940s when you had rationing that makes
certain that is the that's what the
democrats expect us to
to to accept they should have they put
together some cricket patties yeah
justin clark says remember when
cartman's mom tried to make a 37th
trimester abortion legal hard to
distinguish reality from the satire as
you discussed recently that that's not
really satire there was a andy noe
shared this with me there was a
some antifa woman in oregon who was
bragging about getting an abortion at
seven months
that's like the baby was seven months
old no this the
sh
no this is in her 37th trimester oh
thirty seven
i mean sure kids can be a pain but
really no
all right let's grab some what do we got
here let's find a good one there was a
good one i saw a moment ago where did it
go yeah these super chats are great you
guys are awesome is that man look at all
those comments yeah cabbage says tim
case is my favorite thing to listen to
at work i just became a member and i
often delay so i have enough to get
through the day we need an app i know
yo it's like the website's been up for
like a year and a half and it's only
been in the form it's been in for like
10 months
with like channels and new shows we can
only go as fast as humans can go that's
the hard thing so sign up become a
member if you want to support our work
we've got a ton of stuff going on we're
gonna be doing a big marketing campaign
for tales from the inverted world
because if you guys haven't seen it man
go to youtube.com tails from the
inverted world search for it
the latest episode's 40 minutes
and it is like hunter s thompson meets
the x-files but it's a real story shane
cashman went down to georgia to look for
the lost confederate gold and he tells
the story of what it was like and it was
creepy he met crazy people witches
someone threatened to kill him no joke
because it's like people don't realize
that that history of the civil war runs
deep in these towns the town where
jefferson just dissolved the confederacy
they still feel all of that and so
he shows up and someone left him a
voicemail like they were going to kill
him if he didn't stop trying to find out
where this gold was and there are ufos
because there's military research stuff
going on and people come out and they
see these weird things in the sky so
it's really cool stuff it's like real
life x-files almost
so we're going to be doing a big push
for that because the episodes have just
gotten so amazing production quality has
been upped dramatically the episodes are
going to be upwards of an hour long each
and we've got i think 10 episodes this
season and then we're gonna be launching
another show with shane where's going to
do a weekly conversation show about
weird wild stories and that will just be
the the consistent conversation that
happens when the when the seasonal shows
uh on you know in production you said
when jefferson ended the confederacy
jefferson davis yeah it was funny
because of his first name you're on a
first name right right your first name
yes i thought he meant the jefferson
moving on up
that's for sure
sherman hemsley
sherman great actor by the way oh
classic yeah he used to watch it as a
kid and all the family which of course
could not ever be made today
because it's just it was just such a
good show you know sometimes i remember
227 because of how much pearl loved
luther vandross
oh steve mcqueen you know why that's
stuck in my head yeah that's that's a
deep cut i know the two two seven i
watched it you know pearl was my
favorite character her social security
number was wow
she did
steve mcqueen says have you heard of
drivenbillboards.net
it's a mobile it's mobile billboards
that go wherever you want i think it
might be perfect for your advertising
campaign i think so too driven
billboards steve mcqueen
billboards
i will look into that and uh let's see
if these companies are going to be like
yo i'm not putting that video on my
truck
and i'd be like why not why not what's
wrong with it why not are you a trans
folk taking money yeah it's money all
right omg puppy says why don't they just
say latin a perfectly acceptable
adjective that's long been used to refer
to hispanics which is strange because
they're not
latin
latin
is a language that's no longer in use
it's latin roots but
latin america but french and romanian
are also
romance languages it's portuguese
um
yeah i i just love it you know my my
wife of course immigrated from cuba
the only way i could make her more
annoyed uh than calling her latinx is if
i did it wearing a che t-shirt
oh nice yeah
that would not anthony floor says i can
see myself i can see myself 20 years
from now watching ian come out on tim
cast irl as a reformed catholic and it
would be the greatest character arc of
all time all right you got it
catholic
trad kathy and
him and matt walsh he's like matt you're
not cutting it jesus wants him
he's shaved he's wearing a button-up
shirt he looks just like sheamus come in
and matt's ripping the bong i'm like
shame is happening to you man that would
actually be funny if like we did a bit
where it's like 10 years in the future
and sheamus has long hair and he's just
like i don't know about all this he kind
of looks like jesus from the pictures
nobody's like long hair and he's like an
atheist secular hippie and then like you
become catholic and you have like a suit
on like sheamus you need to come back
and he's like i don't i don't know man i
don't understand you i'll be funny
all right there was a there was a super
chat i want to see but someone mentioned
uh sending that video to their their mom
maybe i'll find it dbz dragon says tim i
recommend you and the group look up
peter pagosian he's a former portland
state professor of philosophy and his
work on street epistemology is worth the
look we are good friends with peter he's
he's red um uh i periodically talked to
him i've interviewed him before we've uh
uh
yeah
cool dude we should have him on the show
i don't know what his schedule's like
he's a very very busy man very busy man
problem yeah we try very busy get busy
on irl mm-hmm yeah be busy it's good huh
you just need to come all the way across
the country isn't everything that's all
yeah
all right let's see
candace volpis says just got out of the
military here is some tax money back
driving from nc to az thanks for making
this trip more enjoyable hey you
appreciate it man all right cool will
you go through the grand canyon if you
get near that gets really cold have you
ever noticed they've ever driven past
the grand canyon is it cool although i
think all the heat's falling into the
canyon or a lot of times he rises
usually yeah but you would think but
it's like hitting the ground and then
rising up above the base
i only went to the grand canyon once and
it was the x-files uh series finale
that's awesome and uh
we had all this uh well we thought we
had all this weed but it kind of got
lost at the airport anyway it was it was
a fun time it was a fun trip it was a
fun trip wow yeah watch out for black
guys e02 dave says
trump drained the water from the swamp
and exposed the creatures
quite the achievement considering all
the snakes in the grass that is it is a
fair point he made it he may not have
emptied the swamp but he did do a little
and all of a sudden we could see a lot
being exposed yeah shout out to our good
enemy john bolton i'll make the joke
about good friends for a lot of people
but not him coming on tv and outright
saying like i've staged coup d'etat in
many countries
and then from was like he shouldn't i
post jokes
like
stop
stay on the oop k
yo but it's like the all of the stuff
that was supposedly a secret is just
coming out in the open now after trump
bolton's like yeah i did it and
everyone's like wow well you know at one
point secrets mattered because
you know you'd have a media that would
expose them and now it's like you got uh
you know you got hunter biden
you know showing off showing off the
whole butcher fact uh butcher
shop you know walking around weighing
the crack got the hookers
the nice thing is you know people are
like oh this is a terrible security
breach no it isn't
because there's nothing you could do to
blackmail this guy what what are the
chinese having
we have we have the real dirt on you
what do you get though
three hookers at a time
all right scallywag swagger says hollow
points aren't banned that's a lie they
expand to stop overpenetration and
collateral life loss you talk about
desantis but seem to forget he signed
red flag laws
trump said i like taking the guns first
and then going to the courts or whatever
if only we had some sort of process
where we could question the candidate
before deciding if they were finally a
nominee would you like i wonder what
that would be that would be amazing that
would be really interesting we might
want to institute something like that
also i had a similar uh notion yesterday
uh somebody was saying well how are we
going to know what the framers said if
only there was some i wonder if there
was maybe a document or maybe a way to
away perhaps they would have written it
a way to permanently etch your thoughts
and maybe they would have written down
additionally things they thought about
the things they wrote down in the first
place
would have been so useful maybe 81 of
them yeah
that's crazy are there 81 aren't there
81 federal newspapers i think so yeah
jason there are a couple lesser federal
papers i'm only getting that from from
hamilton i only remember that from
hamilton there are some actual
federalist people
where they compare and fight over star
trek versus right star wars they have a
lot of yeah those are really cool the
lesser known ones with kind of esoteric
conflicts jason d says draining the
swamp did not rid us of the monsters it
exposed the monsters and in that trump
certainly succeeded
again again fair point fair point same
point
all right daniel spratt says look into
lure is what it's called the lord
building a streaming service with
non-woke content marcus pittman is the
guy behind it how do you spell that does
it say lore it's like l-o-o-r i think
lure
it's like the text is really small i
thought it would be l your tv maybe it's
lure dot tv yeah is that it 85 they were
85 they're 85 85 federalist people i
know hamilton wrote 51. all right oh wow
john jay wrote eight i think there was
and jk rowling wrote two i'm sure yes
sounds right yes russ says any comment
about the ray epps washington post story
his reasoning seems plausible i didn't
see it what was it does anybody see it
uh i did not think i can comment there
was a time it was the new york times and
they said you know here here's this
victim yeah and it's like
who's on video telling people to engage
in entering the capital is a victim and
me a guy who read the news is included
in this this this video montage by
raskin reading the news is
yes you have correctly assessed the
situation
yeah these people are duplicitous
deceitful
and um
you know i am i am unhappy with the
representation that he is present he is
bringing forth in montgomery county in
maryland where many of my employees
actually live yeah
you must uh he's montgomery oh yeah it
surrounds federer oh that's right okay
there you go right twerking for liberty
that's what you need to do
yeah liberty yeah
all right there was that one i wanted to
find someone mentioning
them i don't want to culturally
appropriate his twerking exactly you got
to be careful with that waffle sensei
says trump will give the left the
ammunition they need to hurt desantis
because trump is a comedian trump needs
to walk away but he won't the poll said
94 of democrats will vote against trump
again that's true
no that's that is true but then again
look
trump's saying he's going to run people
around him say he's going to run
trump doesn't know where he's going to
run or not he's running he really wants
he he could remember how he keeps saying
i'm gonna make an announcement you're
gonna be very happy he wrote that note
the note says kurt you'll be very happy
with me okay you'll be happy with what
you see he says of course i framed it
well sure why not on a big gold frame
frame yeah he's a garish gold frame
he's an interesting cat and i gotta say
i miss the entertainment value oh it was
fun uh but but it's been seven years and
it's a legit question he came down they
asked all the time it's a legit question
is this is the trump act still the best
way forward for us yeah you mentioned
his lack of discipline uh that's
we're talking about posing a military
commander it's got to be the most
disciplined i believe of the you use the
choices
in a really long time uh that's that's
true who was the last day i mean bush
was probably into
discipline maybe but that's personal i
think that's a different that's a
different guy
he always seemed like a guy who probably
you don't want to know what he's going
on behind closed doors you know and
laura always has that laura
laura laura was uh laura was stern and
uh unforgiving unyielding laura ashley
dress or ashley dresses
wear something conservative i want you
to look like you're going to church on
easter oh my gosh yeah
that's hot
[Laughter]
there we go
it's the curtain libby show yeah i love
it
i'm looking for a super chat that's why
i start wondering what in the meantime
buy my book people yeah where can people
get that we'll be back well i'm glad you
asked that ian you can get we'll be back
the phone rise of america at amazon or
barnes noble or your fine purveyor of
fine books
uh and i want to emphasize it is not a
bataan death march of people going you
know if locks used to say well hobbes
pointed that it is not that did you do a
uh did you do an audio book version they
wanted me to but i i said look no one
wants to listen to me for
eight hours i don't think anybody wants
to listen to me for two hours i think
they might the guy driving from north
carolina to arizona oh yeah that poor
guy i might drive him off the road
his annoying nasal voice doesn't stop
i'm gonna find myself at the bottom of
the grand canyon
that's perfect i can't find i can't find
that there was one i really wanted to
read someone said that they sent the uh
the video to their like aunt or
something oh i saw that yeah
they responded with like okay this is
weird this stuff's like nonsense and it
opened the door to conversation
the key to ending the political conflict
in this country is one man a hero as it
were
who put everything upon his shoulders
twerking fat man and tidy whitey's oh my
god would it be great if he was like if
he was like a giant mega guy
he's like i work in hvac he went out he
went out
i went out to twerk because i knew i
knew i would be the set i would be the
red pill i will jump on the grenade a
single tear comes from his eyes it takes
all his clothes
someone's gotta do it for america all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have the
uncensored after hours show up at about
11 p.m so we will see you all there it's
gonna be a lot of fun again that's at
timcast.com sign up i know some people
have mentioned we've been having issues
there's an issue with paypal that
happens like at around like one year so
some people were affected by and some
weren't and we had no idea it would
happen so just at the one year mark
everybody a bunch of people were like
whoa weird so we're working on fixing it
and um i knew it was going to happen
that the announcement's not ready but
it's not our fault it's the other
company's fault but we'll we'll it's
okay it's okay we're excited for what's
to come and y'all are gonna be really
excited when we announce this stuff so
go to timcast.com click sign up support
our work you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me personally at
tim cast kurt you want to shout anything
out
well uh
first of all thank all you guys for
having me out here uh
you know lydia libby ian and of course
you tim i always i always love coming
out here because i'm not surrounded by
damn communists like i am in los angeles
uh get the book
i like i said i would like ragnary to
release my family and if i don't sell
books
they will be in bondage
like george bush but we're not going to
go down that road again
thanks for having me
shouting things out i will shout out the
post millennial i'm at the post
millennial every day and you should come
check it out i'm at libby evans on
twitter and also instagram
you follow me iancrosslin.net go through
that portal to any of my social media
accounts if you want to follow me there
thank you for being a part of this up
and down
wild ride man kurt i love you thank you
for coming out ian you complete me you
must do this
again see you guys later it is actually
so fun being on this show it's fun
i literally fly across the country
that's right just to be honest
we're happy to bring you out for sure
thank you thank you guys all very much
for tuning in this evening and i wanted
to say before we go that you're not
going to change the minds of hardcore
leftists but you might change the minds
of people who haven't seen for example
trump's whole speech where he talked
about the quote very fine people and
stuff like that people who watch the
full context often their minds are
changed like that super chat that we did
not have a chance to get to
very important it is possible give
people the full contacts and be patient
with them you guys can follow me on
twitter mines.com at sourpatchlits as
well as sourpatchlits.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in about an hour thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you